and let's jump into the first major
story this stuff freaks me out
facebook and instagram non-person trump
reports the daily mail
platforms ban ex-president's interview
with daughter-in-law laura
where she signals he will run for
president in 2024.
facebook and instagram pulled the clip
because it featured trump
speaking that's it so what does that
mean if i
if i pull up an old video of the
apprentice are they are they going to
pull it down now
you can't no no more apprentice my guess
is no because it's so
haphazard and irrelevant of why they're
just we try because it's politically
motivated
should we should we try i don't usually
poke the beast unless i need to
be why don't you get to that billion
dollar media company first
and then we'll try it and then just like
create the donald trump archive yes
where we just like i mean what happens
if 60 minutes decided to interview
the former president the 45th president
of the united states
and then they put up clips on youtube or
tucker carlson
or whomever else
very perfect i got to clear it because
facebook said they didn't want to do
political ads anymore maybe they thought
it was a political ad no
no no no they said it was because it was
they literally said look
the voice of donald trump what if i what
if we do you know
what are those things they do where they
deep fake a voice was that called the
defecting probably
yeah they they did that thing with joe
rogan where it was called like not joe
rogan.com or something
and they would type things in and it
sounded like joe rogan was saying them
what if we just do that what if we get a
donald trump voice changer and so we do
this show
with a mod on so all of our voices are
donald trump
all talking and arguing with each other
i love it poke the beast
the beast test the algorithm facebook we
persuaded you very easily
fake voices that's fun no but this is
this is this is wait can we not do
mannerisms can we not do slogans can we
not even do imitations now
gina that's it we're banned
no more facebook everybody it was
trump's
son's wife was on facebook talking on
video talking saying that donald trump
was gonna run and there was a clip of
his
voice they didn't say he was gonna run i
guess trump said people who want him to
run should have hope
and that's always because there's a
bunch of laws that don't come into play
as soon as you say you're running for
president
oh so that's why they always wait till
the last minute like we know they're
gonna run
i think this is a really strong
indication trump will end up running
he's gonna be 78 years old he's going to
run for president
and they're going to ban him twitter it
was like we're not letting him back on
even if he does run for president dude i
look at the stuff that's going on today
you know all of this stuff all over the
world
the stuff that's happening in media and
it's just been blatant
over and over again like that video the
verge published this video of a google
meeting when trump won the election
and there's people crying right and it's
like the ceo and he's like we know how
everyone's upset about this
it's like we're never gonna let that
happen again yeah yeah
yeah we see it happening right in front
of us and then
you know nothing happens you know you
know you know what you know why nothing
happens the people that
run facebook and these other companies
are now
in charge of uh anti-trust division at
the department of justice
and vice versa yeah there's just like a
steady flow back and forth
matt stoller's really been on top of
this about who which the personnel from
which company is now
at doj no one is there to prosecute it
why
because we're living in a techno
corporate fascist state
where the democratic progressive left
and the corporations have
fused in all of their intentions and
they're acting in concert and they will
never check each other
because all they want to do is check us
well here's here's the problem with the
with the democratic progressive left
that the anti-establishment left sides
with them more often than not because
they're given candy
you know so the democrats are like
here's aoc to say another thing is
racist
and these these far leftists insurgent
types revolutionary types anti-types who
should oppose joe biden everything he
stands for support him
they come out they're like well we don't
like joe biden we just voted for him
because trump is bad
it's like so you think the establishment
should regain control of the white house
and do all that stuff
sure i guess but more often than not
they dangle red meat from people like
aoc and bernie sanders in front of the
far
the far left and the and the socialists
and they just take it
you take it so there are a lot of
anti-woke leftists who want a worker's
revolution and all that stuff
okay stop siding with the establishment
donald trump was not the base of power
in this country even as president which
was hilarious
he got some things done he had power as
president but the entire machine was
against him for two years
the republican party was against him
it's like who was it trey gowdy
when the russia thing comes up they're
like well we better look into this stuff
because
we want to make sure we're being
thorough it's like the guy's the the
effect of the leader of your party but
they hated him
they wanted all of that stuff to happen
to just you know slow him up
you got to judge people by their actions
not by their words right so if these
people on the far
left are voting for the establishment
supporting the establishment supporting
the technical corporate fascist
tyranny that we live under now they
clearly aren't really interested in a
workers revolution
it's sad and funny watching them get
banned you know like like
when they come after crowder and they've
been coming after crowder i think they
they just took down another one of his
videos like in the past couple of hours
so i want to be careful too because like
obviously i know i know crowder
and uh so you know every time something
like this happens i'll be like yo can
you confirm what's going on
so i don't know if he's mentioned it yet
but you know i've been talking to him
they're taking down more of his more of
his
videos and they're doing it in creepy
ways like okay this one's not a strike
but
we're giving you a warning here the
reason this is is just outright awful
infuriating because he didn't break any
rules they're lying
they're taking down videos where he
literally cites the cdc
which is what he's supposed to do and he
is one of the staunchest
like most ardent and high profile
advocates defending free speech for
literally everyone including these
leftists who complain all the time
so when they go after him it's like he
would go to like events where people
were protesting and sit down and be like
debate me have a conversation change my
mind instead of fighting let's have a
real and they're great they're great
they're amazing that's what kind of made
him super famous was was that stuff
i mean he's he's had a lot of you know
thing a lot of uh
shows he's hit out of the park but but
here's what i'm trying to say
when i see these progressives get nuked
i go
don't ban them please these people have
a right to be on the platform they have
a right to their channels
there was one person who got banned from
youtube and i followed this stuff i
followed the censorship i see the
progressives saying these progressives
just got banned where's the free speech
you know freeze peach people and i'm
like i'm right here yo
give them their channels back who do i
gotta email one of them was just like
ragging on me non-stop
and i'm like i don't care i want them to
rag on me and say all the mean things
about me that's their right to do so
good we don't want a mono culture where
only
you know the oracle can speak down from
the high heavens
but you know the problem is i say it's
sad because i don't want to happen
but it's kind of funny admittedly it's
funny like watching someone melt
like it's horrifying but it's like haha
or watching someone fall down and get
hurt like people laugh
no it's it's funny it's like it's the
guy who is smacking you in the face over
and over again
then getting smacked in the face and you
want to be
and you want to be like dude we don't
want the violence i get they were
hitting me
don't hit them let's stop everything but
we want to laugh about it's like if i'm
against violence
i don't want them to be fall violence if
i support free speech
and these people are advocating for my
destruction it's really annoying
that when they get censored of course
i'm going to defend them
what's frustrating about it is look the
people who believe in individual
liberties
and free speech we're the good guys we
are the good guys
because we stand up even for our enemies
it's like i grew up watching batman and
you know batman would do
the joker falls of a building and batman
grabs his hand and doesn't let him fall
sherlock holmes the the bad guy lord uh
what's his name
blackwood or whatever falls and then
sherlock he's like all right and he
pulls him back up the good guy saves the
bad problem is if you watch gi joe when
cobra commander would fall
duke would grab him and he'd be like
help me duke and duke would be pull him
up and then cooperate thanks and he'd
push him off the ledge
exactly so like at what point do you
stop helping your enemies i don't know
that's the thing people are going
through right now
that's exactly it don't lose your moral
compass these people
are are going ha ha ha you're getting
censored you stupid bigot
and then when the ground falls out from
under them we reach down grab them and
say
hold my hand brother and we pull them up
and then as soon as we do they push us
off the edge and say ban them now
that's the problem that's the worst this
reminds me
of this whole thing going on right now
james lindsey and his sort of style on
twitter
right it's like it's funny it's
hilarious and i totally get it
politeness has gotten us nowhere right
and that's his approach right he's like
look politeness isn't gonna get us
anywhere
we need to start being aggressive and
crude and throw manners out the window
because manners are political
correctness which is you know tyranny
which is mind control etc
and it's a tough spot to be in holding
your
moral compass true staying true to your
values when doing that is
like paving the road to your own demise
it's true man but you know this
you i thought about this we've we've got
people who believe the ends justify the
means and so they
think by being evil people who suppress
people's rights who take away their
freedom of speech
that as soon as they take over then
everything can can be fine but there's
no end you never meet the end
once they have their glorious revolution
they must fight to protect it
from those who would stage another
glorious revolution and the ones that
they've inspired to be cruel and use
evil
are going to be the ones that are coming
up to try and stop them so the
the means you use are the means that
will be used against you exactly
and so that's why i just can never agree
but maybe it means we just sit back and
watch the world burn
because what i see happening now is
these people who are authoritarian
they're despotic
they're liars they're hypocrites people
like aoc she screams donald trump is
putting kids in concentration camps
now that it's happening under biden what
did she say today there is no migrant
crisis so this is the other day she said
there is no migrant crisis
it's a crisis of imperialism lady
there's a migrant crisis
even abc's pointing it out they're
hypocrites so what's happening is i'm
watching these people go town to town
literally burning these towns down that
literally happened last year
and we're told being calm polite
rational
and staying true to our beliefs is the
only way forward
but they're still burning the cities
down both figuratively and literally so
what do we do
do we decide to burn things down back
well that's just gonna make everything
burn down faster
and that's what they want so i can only
i can only hope that we have this little
fortified space
whereas everything else burns down
because weak cowardly people
give in and let them do it we will have
some some sanctuary
you real you know what you sound like
right now you sound like john gold
that's the main character of ein rand's
atlas [ __ ] you know what i mean it's
like okay you guys are gonna burn the
world down well guess what i'm going to
build my own world and you can't come
and that's a little bit about what we're
doing in the liminal order it's what
you're trying to do
is what you are doing you want to build
your own walled garden
with no masters with no interference
from the other institutions and the big
tech
companies and all that be left alone
yeah and limit order is extremely
successful like that mentality works
it really does work because people are
feeling the same thing and they want a
space that's protected from all this
madness and mayhem bro you know what you
know what it is is
there's very few people like us okay the
people who are watching this
you watch it for a reason i imagine
we're all part of this
ideology of some kind of classical
liberalism
freedom and i'm sure there's probably a
lot of more authoritarian right
individuals who watch for the sake of
opposing the authoritarian left
but i think most people who watch
because we actually we've had events
we've done polls our libertarian left or
libertarian right mostly in moderate
there's just very few of us people who
are willing to stand up and defend
the rights of the individual and freedom
and that we start seeing how this cult
mentality seeps through everything
and it's because regular people don't
care don't want to be involved
they just want to sit down and be told
what to think
and i don't i'm not trying to be mean to
most people but it really is the guy in
the workplace who's like
i don't want to get into a fight with
anybody i don't talk about politics
you're just going to sit here to become
a target being on video and speaking
your mind like this is
it it is a freaky proposition and it
puts you in a bit of a vulnerable state
but also it gives you immense power
once you start to do it and realize not
that you're untouchable but that you're
stronger than real
once you do become more or less
untouchable uh it's
it's a crazy liberating feeling it's
empowering and it's
more fueled to actually continue
speaking the truth
i i worry that if you know obviously we
want to see crowder get taken out
but if if crowder does get taken out tim
like
you're you're like the lead dog then yep
i don't know about me i don't think
we're that big
like crowder's got five something
millions who's between you and crowder
in this same space jordan peterson
jordan peterson's got way more subs
i mean he's way bigger way more
influential just saying man
if crowder goes but in terms of content
more attention
will be the same team that's sweating
crowders
content that just like you and steven
are very different like he's a
kind of comedian comedian like offensive
comedy of comedians i don't i
don't he really rides the line but i
hate that idea offensive comedy
he does like comedy edgy comedy he's not
like a
gentle comic he's like i'm kind of
hardcore i've watched crowder
i've watched family guy guess which one
has more race-based
stereotype-based jokes and surprises
yeah and that's that's that's on tv
every day all day every day influencing
kids and everybody and good i think it's
a funny show
crowder is nowhere near i don't want
them to ban
south park but if you watch one episode
of south park
it's a thousand times worse than
anything any of us are saying i'm
concerned with the terms of service of
youtube when we were writing our terms
of service and minds we were like what
if we just slide a little thing in there
that says and we remain
we retain the right to ban anyone at any
time no matter what say that
if that says that a youtube which it
probably does yes no one's safe
for any reason none of us are saying no
period none of them don't put that
little and all it is is one little
sentence
yep after this regard i might not sound
like john galt
i am not a fan of laissez-faire
capitalism and big corporations that
can do what they want on my private
platform i think
i think that we have you know the people
have to come together and have some kind
of agreement about what we don't let
people do with power
so on on right before i came up here i
tweeted out i had the same thought
libertarianism died with the birth of
the internet which isn't exactly right
but the gist is that the scale of the
internet and the power that
allows people and corporations to accrue
is is the just example prima fashion
evidence is why libertarianism
is failed libertarian philosophy right
would just be like
vladimir you mean you mean big
libertarianism yeah yeah
not not not just leave me alone
libertarianism but like actual political
philosophy libertarianism
if you that the theory would lead you to
say like just let amazon and google do
their thing
just let twitter and facebook do their
thing they're a private company
or they're you know they're they're a
corporation they can do whatever they
want just let hey
build your own right i it's clearly not
happening sorry there's clearly not
happening because
now also there's just the prospect of
the ai right
just like the super dominant ai that's
going to cast a long night over
everybody
and so libertarianism is dead you can't
just let the corporations do whatever
they want
didn't you see wall-e i did don't you
think it would be just so amazing
to be able to just be morbidly obese
with very weak skeletons floating around
in hover chairs
drinking sodas and just having
everything done for you
it's what plants that's what plants need
wrong wrong movie
but you know what i'm talking plants do
you think about wall-e these people
might as well be a
shrub in a in the corner there's really
very little difference between the
wall-e
character and the guy in the pod in the
matrix right
very little very little because you're
just there to serve the system
that's it man yeah i get i get
pessimistic seeing the stuff like with
the with the
the chauvin trial stuff it was really
creepy to see this woman try taking
photos on the court and the judge just
goes well just delete that photo for me
okay moving on
i'm like bro throw her out bar her from
the courtroom
because deleting the photo doesn't
delete the photo yeah it might have
automatically uploaded it to some
servers
absolutely it's already on icloud maybe
and and
so who was she just watching the trial
she was a pr person
apparently thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you